well she just heard the mullah report
has arrived with no further indictments
according to a senior DOJ official that
is it no one else will be indicted in
this investigation for collusion or
anything else so to repeat after all of
this years of it not a single American
citizen has been charged with anything
related to Russian conclusion not one
person not Michael Flynn not Roger stone
not George papadopolis not Paul Manafort
not Carter Page not Donald Trump many of
these people have had their lives ruined
by the Muller investigation some could
die in prison not one of them colluded
with Russia the people on TV have been
lying to you they'll deny it now they'll
tell you this was always about Trump's
taxes or some foreign real estate deal
or hush money he paid to a girlfriend
that's a crock this investigation was
always from day one about collusion with
Russia about betraying this country they
told us that for years and we have the
tape what makes you believe that he has
more indictments because he hasn't
addressed the issues related to criminal
conspiracy as well as any individual
conspiracy involving the Russian and
Russia's yes yeah I think it was very us
that's an area you know something about
that that investigation was developing
while you were still on the job well it
was in terms of looking at what was
going on with the Russians and whether
or not US persons were actively
collaborating colluding cooperating and
involved in a conspiracy with them or
not but also if there's going to be any
member at that stage to believe that
there would now that that would result
in indictments once investigated I
thought at the time that there was going
to be individuals who were going to have
issues with the Department of Justice so
that was the former CIA director one of
countless retired Intel officials you
see parading across your screen every
night all of them paid by MSNBC or CNN
to toe the party line
all of them know better they're lying
it's a habit many then picked up years
ago members of Congress did the same to
pick one among a thousand examples here
tennessee's Steve Cohen telling us that
most of the Trump family is bound for
prison well I think they're getting
closer to knowing that the truths gonna
come out that there was activities with
the Trump campaign and Russia and
releasing those hacks and guiding them
to the states and the localities where
they came from some of that was Jared
Kushner's responsibilities some of it
was Donald Jr I think you're gonna
probably see indictments of both of
those people that man is a sitting
member of Congress he's wearing a
necktie he's on television people
believed him and why wouldn't he he's an
authority figure in this country and he
was lying so was Senator Richard
Blumenthal who has spent years bringing
shame to the state of Connecticut he
embarrassed himself even further with
his mock certainty on this and many many
other occasions there are indictments in
this president's future
they're coming whether they're after his
presidency or during it obviously the
Department of Justice said cannot indict
a sitting president and of course there
was Howard Dean he's the former governor
of Vermont Dean was also if you can
remember that far back to 2004 a
presidential candidate at one point
looked like he was going to be the
nominee of the Democratic Party he went
on to run the DNC he's on television
constantly people have long whispered
that Howard Dean is not all there they
say he yells so much because he can't
think very well they claim he's so slow
it takes him an hour and a half two hour
60 minutes you don't want to believe any
of that's true it sounds cruel on the
other hand they might be right we
believe we may well have a criminal in
the White House and the next step is
going to be the Trump family itself I
expect that there's a good likelihood
Jared Kushner will be invited for longer
money laundering and then we're gonna
have to see how far the Russian
involvement goes this is serious
business these people are undermine
money our democracy it was never serious
business another lie it was ludicrous
it was always ludicrous but no matter
how much evidence you muster you will
never convince congressman Eric sois
well of that soir well is the original
collusion truther there is no element of
the Russia conspiracy that soir well
who's been on the show many times is an
eager to
believe and magnify you really ought to
have an overnight show an AM radio he'd
be able to tell us how Putin seriously
secretly runs Bilderberg CNN of course
loves Erik's wha-whoa for years that
channel has broadcast uncritically
virtually every lunatic claimed swallow
has ever made here's one example it's
looking more and more wolf that Donald
Trump was a part of a criminal campaign
a criminal transition and now presides
over a criminal presidency a criminal
presidency what's criminal is what just
happened we have lived through three
separate investigations into Russia
collusion not just Muller but a
committee in the house and a committee
in the Senate and they spent years
looking in this and in the end they
found nothing but during that time this
country the country they're supposed to
be running has become obviously and
measurably worse suicide drug ADIZ are
up life expectancy is falling the
borders are a mess we have no clue who
lives in this country to the tune of
millions of people maybe tens of
millions we've no idea the schools are a
joke you wouldn't send your kids to him
if you had a choice infrastructure is
crumbling hundreds of thousands of
Americans sleep outside every night so
what are our leaders talking about where
they spend their time obsessing over
what do they get TV bookings to rant
about some irrelevant meeting with a
minor Russian lawyer in Trump Tower
three years ago the New York City Subway
barely works the largest city in the
United States smells like garbage people
are fleeing it what does Bill de Blasio
the mayor talking about he's ranting
about Putin this has been a disaster how
can we let the people who are
responsible for it continue as if it
never happened
how can Eric's whoa whoa and Adam Schiff
keep their seats in the House of
Representatives they should resign how
can Jeff Zucker remain at CNN after we
now know that much of what his network
told us for two years is a total lie and
it is a total lie and what about the
victims of this monstrosity there are
many Roger stone is facing life in
prison he was indicted by it investing
Asian designed to find collusion
indicted at minor charges he was dragged
from his own home in a morning FBI raid
they put an amphibious vehicle outside
his house and pointed an automatic
weapon in his face all to find collusion
but there was no collusion stone is
still looking at life in prison where's
Roger stones pardon his pardon from the
president let's hope it comes very soon
the mauler investigation is over as of
tonight but the records remains for the
sake of this country let's clean it up
quickly and move on